WOLFF DOBSON: Hi, I'm
Wolff Dobson.
DAN GALPIN: I'm Dan Galpin.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And I'm
Bruno Oliveira.
DAN GALPIN: So, money.
True, there are many people who
make games just for fun.
But of course, to many
developers, making money from
games is a crucial part
of their business.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: But they've
still got to
have some fun, right?
DAN GALPIN: Well, of course.
So one of the questions we often
get from developers is
how do I make money
on Android games?
If you're a developer, you
probably wish there was easy
command to do that.
But the truth is, it's
not that simple.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Same thing with
many other questions we
get, like, how do I
get discovered?
How do I get featured?
How do I get that five-star
rating?
How do I get rid of those
pesky bad reviews?
How do I make users
play my game?
And how do I actually
make them buy stuff?
That's a whole bunch
of questions.
DAN GALPIN: Sometimes, these
questions miss a fundamental
point, and that point is that
at the center of everything,
there is a user.
We like users.
They are fascinating,
baffling creatures.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: So instead of
actually trying to answer
those questions up there,
we'll focus on
what's really important.
And it's that guy.
Successful games are the ones
that have many users and where
those users are happy.
If you do that, the odds that
you make tons of money or even
be featured on Google
Play goes up a lot.
WOLFF DOBSON: Which is why
we're going to focus on
driving game installs and making
a great user experience
along with the mechanics of
actually collecting money from
your players.
So let's talk about sign
in with Google.
One think you can do to
grow your game is
to use social features.
We did a user survey recently
and found that users
overwhelmingly trusted Google
to sign in across the web.
This is because users trust
Google not spam their stream.
You can share only what you
want or share it with the
right people.
Last year, we added APIs to
enable users to log in with
their Hulu Plus identity, and
this year, we had access to
the Social Graph.
So quick update from Google+--
500 million users makes Google+
one of the fastest
growing social networks
in history.
We've grown from just 150
million users between last
year and last December.
More than half of our
users are mobile.
We have 135 million active
monthly users in the stream,
and they spend about 12
minutes there daily.
That's a lot of people.
That's a lot of people who
can be playing your game.
If you think about it, Google+
is truly at the heart of our
efforts to create a simpler and
more intuitive experience
for all our users.
It's our social spine
that binds all of
Google's products together.
We have 120 Google+ integrations
to date that
makes the user experience
better on Google.
When you see your friends'
recommendations in Google
Play, you don't think about that
as Google+, but it comes
from that infrastructure.
We're seeing a positive impact
across all our products.
But what does sign in
do for developers?
Well first and foremost,
it will help
drive Android installs.
There's a huge cliff getting
users to install your app
before they can play it, and
we can help with that.
I'll show how in a minute.
Secondly is getting user
growth through
targeted social sharing.
Google+ allows you to share the
right information with the
right people.
So that means gamers sharing
information with gamers.
You also have access to Google+
profiles and Social
Graph, which will give
you a lot of
information about your users.
And finally, users
obviously trust
Google as a login provider.
So what does this look
like in a game?
Here's my game, "Nostalgic
Racer," with Google+ sign in,
and it's got a Google+
login button.
You can fit into your interface
any way you want.
If you click on that, I get a
Google-provided permissions dialogue.
There are two halves to it.
The first indicates that
I am sharing my Social
Graph with this app.
From this dialogue, you can even
edit which subset of the
graph you want it to see.
I might not want to share
friends and family with this
app, but I want to share
all my gamer friends.
Second half controls who
might see that I am
playing this game.
So if you want your high school
friends to see that you
are playing but not your mom,
you can make that happen.
So after I click OK, I'm back
to the game, and you can see
that I am completely
logged in.
Well technically, Bruno is
completely logged in.
If your users have signed in
to Google+ on their phone--
and this is very, very likely--
using G+ Sign-In gets
them signed in with one dialogue
very efficiently,
with as little as two
clicks if they
like the default settings.
So you, the game developer,
now have access to their
profile information, and you
have a better idea of who's
playing your game.
And you can see their Social
Graph, so you can see if they
have friends who also play this
game or friends who might
want to play this game.
Now, let's say I play this game
a whole lot and get an
awesome time on one of the
tracks in "Nostalgic Racer." I
want to post about it, and I
want to make an interactive
post about this track
in particular.
So let's see an interactive
post.
Here's one that I'm doing
to Todd and Bruno.
I've mentioned them by name, and
I'm giving them a button
to click to challenge me
on 8-Bit Speedway.
The two big things here--
first, with the Social Graph
data available, you can see
which of my friends are playing
"Nostalgic Racer" and
pre-fill the dialogue
with their names.
And secondly, by mentioning
Todd and Bruno by name,
they're really going
to see this.
Since I've mentioned them
explicitly, depending on their
settings, they're going to see
a notification on their G+
stream, their email,
the web, even a
notification on their phone.
It's a really high
visibility share.
So here's the post
in the stream.
You've got a Challenge button,
and people will come to play.
On the web, if you click on the
Challenge button, it might
take you to your developer
website that will show them
how to install the game.
On your phone, if you click
on this link, you will go
straight to the app itself.
There are dozens of actions
you can choose.
Challenges is one of them.
That button can go to the exact
level in your game or
provide some kind of help
in a social game,
anything you want.
And this is huge.
If you click on one of these
links but you haven't
installed the Android app, it
will take you directly to the
Play Store.
That's awesome.
That's a great way to
drive installs.
There's tons more
with Google+.
We have over-the-air installs
off your website.
We have analytics.
We have +1 button sharing, and
we even have the Hangouts API
for the web.
So check it out on
developers.google.com/+.
So sign in with Google+ can help
bring audience installs
to your game, but you game has
to be awesome for those
players have fun.
Dan's going to talk
about that.
DAN GALPIN: My name is Dan,
and I am an Android gamer.
Really.
One of the great things that
happened between last year at
GDC and this year is that we
published quality guidelines.
To get to these quality
guidelines, go to
developer.android.com
and click Distribute
and click App Quality.
So here they are, core app
quality guidelines.
There's a lot of stuff here that
games often get wrong.
We've been telling game
developers for years to make
sure their game navigates the
Android way with the Back
button being used to
close their game.
And we're gratified that
users seem to agree.
Bad back button support
leads to bad reviews.
Remember that this also applies
to the volume buttons.
Let the system handle
them, and show the
default volume controls.
One thing that our Featuring
QA team cares lots about is
making sure that your
game doesn't have a
vestigial menu key.
To remove it, target the latest
SDK that you can test
on, which, of course,
should be 17.
Targeting the most recent SDK
version also turns off
compatibility hacks that can
impact game performance, so
it's a good thing.
Don't spam your users
with notifications.
Also, offer your users precise
control over which
notifications they are
shown and when.
You'll not only get better
ratings, but you'll also
encourage users with newer
devices to not use the Android
method of blocking all
notifications.
Don't use permissions
that you don't need.
It's really unlikely that you'll
need to get access to
sensitive user data.
From last year, here's stuff
not to require, really.
Feel free to pause and look
more closely at this list.
And don't consider this
an exhaustive list.
And sending/receiving SMS is
particularly bad, but using
any of these permissions will
make it difficult to get a
game featured.
We've also talked quite a bit
about audio, because no one
likes random audio coming
from their pants,
especially your boss.
Do time consuming tasks
in the background.
Develop with strict
mode enabled.
Make sure that you don't
get red flashes.
Our testers will do it.
Also make sure that you support
graphics for lots of
form factors.
It turns out that our quality
team mostly has access to our
Nexus devices.
And if your game can work well
with reasonable text sizes and
touch targets on all of our
Nexus devices, there's a good
chance the game will work
well on other devices.
We also test on some other
extremely popular and
problematic devices.
If you're text isn't legible
or if the game requires
smaller fingers, we
have a problem.
And of course, if you want to
get featured, you'd better
have a great feature graphic.
Remember that many users will
see your graphic on a phone.
Phones are small, and the same
1024 times 500 bitmap that you
see on the web Google Play Store
is scaled down by Google
Play to fit the smaller form
factor of a phone.
You'll need to have large text
with excellent contrast if it
will be readable.
This title is legible, but on
the device, this subtitle is
pretty much gone.
And since I can't necessarily
recognize that stylized ball
as a soccer ball, on the device,
I might miss the
reference to the game I love.
But the best part about our core
app quality guidelines is
they come with tests you
can hand your QA team.
So remember, to find out
more about this, got to
developer.android.com, and
under the Distribute tab,
select App Quality.
We've also talked about game
controllers in the past.
We've added support for standard
HID game controllers
in Honeycomb, and it have been
gratifying to see so many
games having some form of
limited support for them.
So one of my favorite games is
"Nostalgic Racer," and I was
really excited to see that
they have support for
nostalgic controller.
I spent lots for my nostalgic
controller, so I'm the kind of
gamer that sees the cost
of your game as being
incremental.
And then I find that the menus
don't navigate, and there
isn't a good set of
default controls.
And I can't use nostalgic
controller with the game when
my Nexus 10 is connected
to my TV.
So make gamers like me happy.
Ship games that really support
controllers, in
menus and in the game.
If you're going to have
elaborate configuration
screens, great.
But also have great defaults.
Almost every controller
will work well in
menus with these settings.
And if your game only needs
digital controls or buttons,
this will be a great
set of defaults.
One thing to note is that I
suggest supporting both D-pad
center and A. And the reason for
this is that, while most
HID controllers will have these
buttons-- and we do a
great job of mapping these to
reasonable defaults for D-pad
and D-pad center.
But for some reason, we decided
to map both A and B to
the back button.
And this doesn't really make
sense to most users as they
are typically used to having
the A button perform an
affirmative action.
So make sure to actually
map the button that
way within your UI.
Here are some other you might
want to consider, but you
shouldn't rely on these
buttons being there--
some more buttons the standard
controllers will have.
One other note, you get generic
motion events for
analog joysticks.
You also get them from D-pads
that are set up as hat
switches, which is
very common.
A single-motion event, however,
can have both a hat
switch and analog motion.
And if you had the analog event,
you must handle the hat
switch event as well if you wish
to use the adding your
game because otherwise the
system will think you've
handled the analog event and
you won't get the generated
D-pad event.
So here are some common axes
that controllers will have.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: So,
in-app billing.
In-app billing is actually
pretty cool.
Every time we talk about in-app
billing to someone, we
sort of expect them to go
something like this.
But then, to our surprise, in
previous versions of the API,
some people went
more like that.
We didn't really understand
why that happened because
in-app billing is actually
pretty simple.
You just do that, and the item
is purchased, right?
It's no problem.
DAN GALPIN: Wait, don't you
have to do more than that?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: More
than that?
OK, I'm actually
oversimplifying
just a little bit.
You actually have to have the
code that handles the purchase
state changes.
But then it's still not
that complicated.
DAN GALPIN: But what if
the app is sleeping?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: OK, if the app
is sleeping when that happens,
then you should probably just
add a broadcast receiver just
make sure you don't
miss that message.
But that's still
pretty simple.
DAN GALPIN: But broadcasters
receives can't
run for a long time.
So what if you have to do
lots of database work or
networking?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Hmm,
that's true.
Real applications have
to do that, right?
So you should probably just
add a very simple and
straightforward service,
something like that.
And that's going to take care
of handling that for you.
As you could see, the code is
very straightforward and
simple to understand.
DAN GALPIN: But what if you're
using managed items?
Don't you need to make sure
that you persist those,
because you can't call Google
Play very often
to check for them?
DAN GALPIN: That's true.
So everybody loves
databases, right?
So I think you can just add some
database code to your app
just to make sure that you
store the purchases.
And then you don't have to make
the calls all the time.
Oh, and they should also
obfuscate that some way,
because otherwise, users can
just hack into that and alter.
But it's still pretty
simple, right?
You don't believe me.
So why does it get
so complicated?
Let's start with the simplest
possible case.
So the user just wants
to buy something.
And they buy something, and it
gets delivered to the app.
So, so far, no problem, right?
DAN GALPIN: Thanks, bro.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
So not a problem so far.
But suppose that instead,
the app is sleeping.
What happens in that case?
In that case, if the app is
not running, sleeping, or
something else, a different
guy has
to pick up the package.
And that guy is the broadcast
receiver.
And then that guy has to take
care of delivering the package
to the app when it wakes up.
DAN GALPIN: Thanks, bro.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
And that's when problems can
happen, because suppose that
that guy is not as reliable as
you think, and he drops the
package or loses the package.
So in V2, there are actually
many components that have to
work together to ensure
that the user's
purchase is handled correctly.
And it can get a little
complicated.
In comparison, here is
what the Version 3
diagram looks like.
No, actually, let's use more
of the slide for that.
That's not going to fit.
Let's use a full slide.
That's better.
So the diagram for V2 is very
simple, but it has seven
sub-components.
And we're going to spend the
next several minutes
discussing each of the
components, sub-components,
and also the sub-sub-components.
DAN GALPIN: And they're
pastels.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
Actually, just kidding.
This is the diagram for
in-app billing V3.
It's much simpler, right?
So the main improvement in V3
is that API calls are now
synchronous.
So this means that your
application can get a response
right away.
And it's much more
straightforward to think
about, too.
For instance, if you want to
buy something like 50 gold
coins, all they have to do is
make a request that looks
something like, buy
50 gold coins.
And guess what.
If the purchase is OK, the API
is going to return something
that's pretty simple--
like say, OK.
And if you are used to V2, you
probably remember that listing
the items that are owned by a
particular user is a very
expensive operation.
So you couldn't call
it all the time.
So you had to do that
very sparingly.
So your whole code had to be
structured around that
limitation.
In contrast, in V3, Google Play
actually implements a
client-side cache and takes care
of keeping that in sync
with the server for you.
This means that calling restore
purchases is actually
very cheap, and you can do that
as often as you need.
For example, you could just
do that every time the
application starts, so you know
what items the user owns.
So I probably sound like I'm
trying to sell you something.
So if you're a developer, then
over the years, you're
probably grown a healthy
mistrust of people that don't
show you any code.
So, let's stop with the sales
and move on to something
that's entirely different.
So let's talk about
selling stuff.
Before you can make any V3 API
calls, you have to check that
it's actually supported.
You can do that by using the
isBillingSupported API call.
The good news is that the in-app
billing Version 3 API
is supported on all devices
running Froyo and above and a
recent version of
the Play Store.
And that corresponds
to over 90% of the
currently active devices.
Now, how do you get a list of
the items that the user owns?
You just call getPurchases.
Remember that this call is
actually pretty cheap.
And also notice that you get the
results right away without
having to implement any
funny callbacks.
Now, this is the moment
your application has
been waiting for.
It's that profound, unique,
magical moment of modern
technology where the user
realizes that your virtual
item is so cool and so awesome
that they are actually willing
to give you real money for it.
Most important of all, at that
moment, you have the user's
trust, so imagine what happens
if you take the user's money
and then lose the purchase.
That's a pretty bad
experience, right?
So again, they've paid
for something, and
they didn't get it.
The least you can expect after
that is a bad review, and
you're probably going to have
to refund that money.
And the user is probably not
going to be a user anymore, so
that's something
to be avoided.
So this is why V3 actually makes
it easier not to lose
purchases by making all items
managed, which means Google
Play keeps track of those
purchases for you.
So how do you launch
this purchase flow?
You can call getBuyIntent to get
an intent that's going to
launch the purchase window.
And then you launch
that intent using
startIntentSenderForResult.
The results of that purchase are
going to come back through
your activities onActivityResult
callback.
At that point, you get the
purchase response code, the
purchase data, and
the signature.
And that's pretty much all there
is for a simple app.
So on start up, you call
getPurchases to see
what the user owns.
When the use wants to purchase
something, you call
getBuyIntent and then
launch that intent.
And on your onActivityResult
callback,
you handle that purchase.
And notice that it's actually
pretty hard to lose a
purchase this way.
You actually have to make an
effort to lose a purchase,
because even if your application
crashed right
after you started the purchase
flow and you never got the
purchase result, it's all right,
because next time your
application executes, you're
going call getPurchases, and
you're going to realize that the
user has bought that item.
So that purchase is not lost.
Now, let's talk about
consumption.
So, consumable items are
a new feature in V3.
So to understand how it works,
let's do it like that.
Somewhere inside Google
Play, there is a box
with my name on it.
I know.
I've seen it.
And inside are all
my virtual items.
So what happens when Bruno
buys COOL ITEM?
When I buy COOL ITEM, an item
called COOL ITEM appears
inside that box.
If you then ask Google Play,
what items does Bruno own,
it's going to return Bruno
owns COOL ITEM.
If I consume that item,
what happens?
The item goes away in flames,
just like that.
I've seen it happen.
In that case, I don't own
that item anymore.
And if I ask Google Play, what
items does Bruno own, it's
going to return the empty set.
So consuming an item
just means that
it's no longer there.
So how do you do that in code?
You just call the
consumePurchases method, and
you just pass it the purchase
token that you got from the
getPurchases.
One question that naturally
arises is when should I
consume something?
That's actually up to you
to decide how to use the
Consumption API.
But we're going to talk about
two of the most-used methods.
You can either consume the item
when it's actually used,
or you can consume it
immediately when it's purchased.
Both of them have advantages
and disadvantages.
To explain method one, I'm going
to give a quick example.
So that's me.
Anyway, that's the
stick figure me.
And those are the items that
I own in Google Play.
Like everybody else, I walk
around with a hit point bar of
top of my head.
And as you know, it's a pretty
dangerous world out there for
stick figure characters.
So I'm probably thinking, before
I venture out there
battling bugs, I am better
off buying a potion.
So I buy this potion, and then
I own this potion, correct?
And then I go out and venture
into the wild world of
programming.
And in the course of my
adventures, I battle several
bugs, and I end up losing a
whole bunch of hit points.
Then I decide to use
that potion.
At that point, your application
is going to
consume the potion and then give
me a full hit point bar.
So that's how it works.
That's a perfectly good
method, but it has a
significant limitation.
So it has to do with how Google
Play actually thinks
about things.
So Google Play only
really knows two
numbers, zero and one.
If your game actually requires
that I should be able to buy
more than one potion, then this
method doesn't work for
you, because if it's a really
dangerous world out there and
I'm going to need more than one
healing potion with me,
then I can't do that
using this method.
Because as soon as you try to
buy a second potion, what's
going to happen is that Google
Play is going to notice that I
already have a potion, so it's
going to see there's a potion
right there.
Why are you asking
for a second one?
That makes no sense.
Google Play can only
count to one.
So you need a better method
if you're going
to implement that.
And that method is immediate
consumption.
In this case, your application
is responsible for managing
the user's inventory.
Notice my excellent rendering
of a plastic bag there.
So when I buy something, you
immediately consume it, and
then you put it into my plastic
bag or inventory or
wallet or anything else
in your application.
And from that point on, you are
the one responsible for
managing the item.
So if I buy a second one, that's
all right with Google
Play because it doesn't know
that I have another one.
So I consume that one and add
it to my inventory, and
everything works.
If you're using this method two,
it's very important to
also check on start up if there
any outstanding items
that you need to consume.
For example, suppose that your
application crashed right
before consuming an item.
You purchased something,
and then you crashed.
What happens is that next time
you start up, you should check
the user's inventory and make
sure that there's nothing
consumable there.
If there is something consumable
that should have
been consumed, this is the time
when you consume it and
credit it to the user's
inventory to make sure that
they didn't lose
that purchase.
So summarizing, on start up,
you call getPurchases.
If you find a potion,
you consume it.
When the user wants to purchase
something, you call
getBuyIntent and then launch
that BuyIntent to get of the
purchase flow.
On your activity's
onActivityResult callback if
the purchase of was successful,
it's ready to
consume it.
When you get the result from the
consumption, you add it to
the inventory, if it was
successful, of course.
Now, let's move on to
a very important
subject, which is security.
So believe it or not, in the
interwebs, there are some
shady characters out there--
shocking, I know--
that may be trying to take your
stuff without paying.
I don't really know what the
technical term is, but I'll
say they are pirates, mostly
because we spent a really long
time drawing this character, and
I had to use it somewhere.
So every time you see a purchase
in your application,
you should ask yourself, is
that purchase legitimate?
And a pirate's job is going
to be to try to
convince you that it is.
And your job is to detect
that they are lying.
No one can actually stop
piracy altogether.
I would be lying to you
if I said as much.
But you can actually make life
pretty hard for pirates.
So here are some defenses
you can employ--
developer payload, signature
verification, and server-side
the validation.
Let's talk about developer
payload.
Developer payload is actually
something really simple.
Its just a tag that gets
attached to every purchase.
And whenever you query
for that purchase, it
comes back with it.
So you should use it
to identify the
owner of the purchase.
And the reason why you want to
identify the owner of the
purchase is to prevent
a replay attack.
So how does that kind
of attack work?
OK, so again, that's me,
a stick figure again.
Like everyone else, not only I
have a hit point bar, but I
also have an evil twin.
So it's that guy over there.
That guy, apart from having a
goatee, isn't very honest.
And last week, he actually
picked up my phone and did a
database dump on the items I had
and then tried to replay
them on his device, hoping
to get items for free.
So when Onurb, my evil twin,
runs your application, you'll
check what items he owns, and
you'll see this purchase.
Now, all you have to do is check
the developer payload,
and you'll know that it's a fake
because it says belongs
to Bruno, and it's Onurb that's
trying to use it.
And it's hard for Onurb to fake
that developer payload
because every purchase is signed
with a private key that
only we have.
So it's very difficult for him
to alter that signature.
So speaking about signatures,
so what is signature
verification?
Well, every application has a
private key and a public key.
The private key is known only to
Google, and the public key
is known to you.
Every time we send a purchase
response, we sign that
purchase with the private key.
And then you can verify that
signature with the public key.
So this means that nobody else
outside of Google can actually
send you a correctly
signed purchase.
So if you check that, you can
be reasonably sure that the
purchase is legitimate.
Now, signature verification is
not actually very difficult.
You can implement it
just using the
standard Java framework.
But it comes with our sample.
So if you are just basing your
code on our sample, you don't
even have to implement that.
Even though signature
verification is pretty cool,
thinking that client-side
security alone is enough would
be a big mistake, because
regardless of how secure you
make things, phones
can be hacked.
So you should definitely add
server-side security to your
application.
On the server side, you should
check the signature again,
just in case the client
has been compromised.
A cool thing you can do in the
server that you can't do in
the client is to check order
numbers, because since you are
receiving every order from every
user, you can check if a
given order number is a
duplicate from another number
that you actually delivered
to someone else.
And it's very important that
you secure the handshake,
because it's not going to do
you any good if you have a
perfectly good signature
verification, order number
verification method
and then the
handshake is very insecure.
So make sure that the handshake
is also very secure.
So just giving you a summary of
the security methods that
we presented--
if you don't do anything, you
are essentially a sitting
duck, and anything can be used
to exploit your application.
If you do only client-side
signature verification, you
are protected against the man
in the middle attack.
So it's going to be hard
to replay purchases.
If in addition to that, you
use the unique developer
payload, then you are also
going to be relatively
protected against purchase
replay attacks.
If you add server-side
verification to that, you're
also going to be safe against a
rarer form of attack, which
is framework compromise.
The actual combination of
methods that's appropriate for
your application is largely
your decision.
We just wanted to outline to
you some of the security
methods that are the
most popular.
DAN GALPIN: And one
more thing.
One of the things that you as
game developers have been
asking for ever since the launch
of in-app billing in
Google Play is the ability
to get real-time pricing
information so that you could
actually display the actual
price that Google Play will
be charging your users.
And it turns out that's one
of the main things we've
added in IAB V3.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Imagine if it
was even localized to the
user's language.
DAN GALPIN: And it is.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And it is.
DAN GALPIN: So you
can actually do
quite a lot with that.
So that's pretty much all we
have on in-app billing and on
game quality.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: We
hope you enjoyed.